the Joe Rogan experience what we're
talking about with anti-semitism one of
the reasons why it's always been so
confusing to me is because it seems to
be this there there there's a lot of
these white supremacists that they they
lean in that or they lean towards
anti-semitism first like almost the the
it's almost more acceptable it's almost
more like they think they can get away
with it they'll find more support online
if like if you say online in a lot of
these forums like if you say hey we got
to get rid of all these black people
you're you're gonna there's gonna be so
many more red flags than if you say we
have to get rid of Jews mm-hmm like that
that doesn't I don't understand that one
because I it's when people look
different from you if you are an Asian
person who is racist against black
people or a black person who's racist
against white people or if someone's
different than you that it's leaf racism
is racism is always disgusting it's
always horrific and ignorant but at
least I can kind of see how you could be
tricked into thinking that way I don't
understand
anti-semitism anti-semitism is not just
a normal bigotry right it's a conspiracy
theory it's a way of understanding and
making sense of the world especially in
times of economic and social upheaval
the reason that anti-semitism is
resurgent right now is because I'm not
justifying it but it's because we're in
going back to our earlier conversation a
time where people are disoriented
they're disaffected they're confused
they're shortchanged and they're looking
for an easy answer so looking for a
scapegoat yes but there's no lines that
point to Jews this is what's so
confusing to me it's like there's no
there's no clue there's no clear thing
do you not I'm saying well it's you have
to wrap your mind around the idea which
is a huge huge huge idea that
anti-semitism is built into the
scaffolding of Western civilization
period it's never going away
you
like think about it like an intellectual
disease that's built into the
foundations of the civilization that we
live in and in times where that
civilization or that's a given society
is healthy anti-semitism along with
xenophobia and racism and all kinds of
other bigotry are sort of kept in check
in when the society becomes unhealthy
and we're living in a deeply unhealthy
society in many different ways right now
anti-semitism is something that people
reach for right it's like if you want to
understand like the Nazi rise to power
you kind of can't understand it without
looking to the fact that there was you
know an incredible economic depression
in Germany and there was a scapegoat and
if you look it's not to justify it but
if you look throughout history right
look at the bubonic plague the bubonic
plague came because of rats to the
European continent that were brought on
ships from Crimea but people did not at
the time they looked why who did they
blame they blame the Jews the Jews were
dying at a lesser rate than their
non-jewish neighbors probably because of
religious rituals that Jews have like
washing your hands before you break
bread and say a blessing dunking in the
ritual baths before the Sabbath and all
of these other things that probably kept
them more protected against the plague
than their neighbors but rather than
looking into it and saying oh maybe
they're doing something right and
something we should mimic their
neighbors said kill the Jews literally
like throw the Jews down the well and it
led to you know massive pogroms killing
Jews for and the claim was that the Jews
literally poisoned the drinking water
throughout Europe so it's like it's this
irrational hatred but it is so so deep
because it goes back to the most
important myth that Western civilization
is built on and that is the Christian
story
Jewish people are it's it's does that
make any sense it makes a lot of sense
but the fact that it still continues
make any sense that reason I it's very
hard to talk about this is because it's
so enormous
it's like accepting the fact that it's
like you have to accept as a
foundational principle that this is
baked into the world that we
live in and we're never gonna cure it
and it's never gonna go completely away
the best thing that we can do is build
healthy cultures that protect certain
virtues like Liberty like freedom of the
individual like religious liberty all
the things like it's not a coincidence
that America has been so good for the
Jews it's because so many of the ideas
that protect minorities and religious
minorities like Jews were sort of for
all of their fault for all of the
founders faults right and they had many
including owning people but you know
George Washington in his he writes this
letter to the first Jewish community of
this country in Rhode Island and he says
something that was then incredibly
radical which is pathetic that it was
but he says you know Jews in America are
not just going to be tolerated they're
gonna possess the same the same
citizenship as everyone else that at the
time was a radical departure from
history in the Islamic world the Jews
had always lived as dim ease as
second-class citizens and in the
Christian world it was worse I mean what
would people forget right it's like
right now radical Islam when it comes to
the religions is the greatest threat to
Jews but for most of its history Islam
was much more tolerant of Jews than
Christianity was which is something
that's kind of like has gotten lost to
history
[Applause]